leonardo dicaprio c'est tout ce que
j'exècre mais moi ils m'auraient
invitait sur son yacht mais j'aurais dit
non je trouve ça bête au parti
juste quelques possibles quand même
parce qu'évidemment donc la chanteuse
taylor swift qui arrive en tête avec son
pâle code 970 voyage en un an ces 8 293
tonnes de carbone c'est l'équivalent de
huit mille personnes et après band kyler
jenner du clan kardashian est là c'est
pire que tout son propre avion elle
c'est un boeing 747 ont fait un faux
procès en fait aux jets privés
l'aviation privée elle représente à
peine 0 04 % d'émissions de co2 dans le
monde 01 04 c'est rien du tout
l'aviation civile en général avec les
avions de transports
l'aviation commerciale et tout avec les
jets privés ça représente à peine 2 20%
d'émissions de co2 il ya la haine de
l'argent en france est un problème en
france on déteste ceux qui ont de
l'argent donc l'avion est un symbole que
représente l'argent le pouvoir de
voyager en jet privé c'est ça évoqué en
interne est ce parce que vous avez de
l'argent où on vous détestent parce que
pour 12 minutes vous prenez un jet qui
va polluer l'équivalent de l'umih
concernant justement moi je fais je le
fais pas je vais pas de 12 minutes mais
je le fais parfois pour 40 minutes si en
voiture ça prend 6 heures passent
parfois par exemple là cet été pour
aller déjeuner chez alain ducasse dans
l'arrière-pays en voiture ça prenait 6
heures alors qu'on est l'écho de monaco
ça m'a pris 25 passes à ses objets des
jeunes et je suis revenu dans les images
de mourir nous pas là il est là fait
même petite voiturette électrique ça la
voiturette électrique
voilà et monte dans son avion en même
temps qu'elle vit [ __ ] par donald kohn
naîtra là parce que ça vous à gages de
masbou ça quand vous entendez un petit
peu ces discours de groen et anti argent
n'est pas hanter écologie en france
n'ont beau ça je sais pas j'ai pas
d'opinion et je suis pas là pour juger
mais par contre quand on parle de deux
de l'impact carbone on pense pas non
plus à l'élevage donc ça aussi ça me
sidère un petit peu mais écoutez
monsieur vous avez votre moral vous avez
votre sens des responsabilités vous
faites ce qui est bon pour les autres ou
pas c'est votre heure c'est votre
problème c'est normal la nacelle bientôt
problème
parce que je veux qu'ils aient ce moment
de solitude donc isabelle adjani 12 gers
une espèce d'amérique aux séries 14 h f
c'est quand même une icône de nos jours
c'est une grande star je pense que tout
le monde sera d'accord avec moi uniqlo
nassar des raisons parce que tu es les
icônes nos jours donne c'est pourquoi
aujourd'hui une star des réseaux ou des
ça devient des icônes aujourd'hui à kim
kardashian ça fait partie des g à 6 mais
tu connais la janais ou pas parce que
isabelle adjani c'est quand même une des
salles existent arenberg rangers et
peine à tous en même temps ils appellent
dans une petite plaine car la même chose
dans la baie james chez les kardashian
c'est une lentille citoyen voilà le prix
y aurait là c'est à peu près tout pour
venger sa ça isabelle adjani est jalouse
de saint phalle vraiment je vous dis un
truc glinka trois césars et qui éclaire
une icône française et mondiale qu'a
fait les plus belles pubs ont mélangé
et on a une meuf qui a été connu pour
une sextape qui incarna vulgarité mais
ça dérange personne que ce dévouement
tendu par sa mère en plus salées bondues
par sa mère qu'elle fait tout est de
qualité et moi je moi j'aime beaucoup et
j'aime beaucoup
après quatre ans de relation l'acteur de
47 ans et dans 74 ans comme tous les
beaux gosses et bien se sépare de sa
nouvelle copine c'est pas la première
fois qu'ils quittent une fille de 25 ans
une d'abord qui a un petit peu plus de
25 mais pas trop il a d'abord
j'ai été super comme estiment ses passes
et laurence
boone film a connu il ya 30 ans pas
sexuel du
g2a machin était très jolie voix la
nouvelle de cet aveux spontanés bon moi
j'aime leonardo dicaprio c'est tout ce
que j'exècre tellement ils m'auraient
invité sur son yacht mais j'aurais dit
non je trouve ça bête non par l'état pas
la tib lui faut un petit monstre et un
jour tu inquiète pas la vivace un total
de 9,5 france que je ne citerai pas il
était à une table et moi je regardais
les gens de septembre mais j'ai quand
même une bonne vue encore et je me suis
dit qu'il y un mec là il a l'air d'un
petit cochon est gelée absolument pas
reconnu se trouver chez havas chic je
trouvais qu'ils aient donc c'était
absolument pas admis ratti vent m'a dit
tu vas pas lui demander un autographe
c'est di caprio je me suis dit [ __ ]
voilà pourquoi t'es pas mieux de leur
monde et ça l'anecdote savez c'est pour
ça je me dis on a passé
je peux dire quelque chose qui
désagrègent il a pas les foules à vous
dire bon alors déjà petite parenthèse on
est en train de le pointer du doigt mais
ça me fait doucement rire cette
hypocrisie pasquin a plus d'un qui le
fait et on n'en parle pas ben oui au
moins ils l'assument c'est une question
goût et laminé jeune femme chacun s'est
dit moi j'aime les hommes plus âgés
chacun ses goûts la petite convoi alors
moi ça me fait vraiment bizarre parce
que j'ai vu grandir il s'avère que c'est
la meilleure amie de mon ex belle fille
si belles chaussures rouges c'est à dire
la laci devançant nickelés assez bas non
c'est sa meilleure amie donc j'ai vu
grandir ça me fait très bizarre de la
voir là il faut savoir que cette jeune
femme dont on ne parlera pas du tout
besoin urgent d'argent m'abonne va pas
être un homme riche aussi ce que je
connais personnellement et que j'aime
beaucoup elle n'a jamais eu besoin de
rien elle a toujours été pourri gâté par
ses parents je pense qu'à une réelle
histoire d'amour à la toujours aussi eu
ce petit truc démis les gars sont un peu
plus âgés et aval mais la manne doit
avoir en belgique en deux ans elle sait
que dans deux ans à les logements de mai
va j'ai envie de te dire je pense
qu'elle a eu son coup de coeur elle l'a
vécue et puis voilà
absolument donc s'il ya eu des premiers
signes avant coureurs qui nous ont été
donnés on a vu des barrières métalliques
qui ont commencé à être dressés on a
demandé aux personnes qui visitaient les
résidences royales de sortir aux
visiteurs donc c'était pour nous déjà
des signes tangibles que le london
bridge code était lancée mais bertrand
comment tu expliques que deux jours
avant on les vues serrer la main de la
nouvelle première ministre qu'il n'y
avait en avait l'air enfin c'est
aujourd'hui de les choses
c'est cette fameuse tache bleue vous
voyez là que l'on voit rien on sait
quand même que le mercredi même si c'est
pas officiel les bruits quand même nous
disent qu'il y aurait eu un axe dans
vasculaire cérébral qui aurait eu lieu
le mercredi cette photo-là et prises le
mardi on sait qu'un accident vasculaire
cérébral est un problème de sens ce
serait déjà voilà le premier signe d'un
dérèglement et on peut dire aussi que
son père qu'elle adorait georges 6 est
décédé en 1952 d'une bosse et c'était
pas exactement la même chose parce
qu'elle est venue en france en 2004 et
je faisais un documentaire autour de
l'ex s'est essayé c'était l'époque de
chirac ouais il ya une il ya eu une ride
elle est arrivée à l'elysée elle est vu
en train elle était à l'elysée alors
elle était toute petite je vais pas
serrer la main mais j'étais à côté d'une
personne à qui est laissée à la main
parce qu'en fait quand vous êtes dans
une pièce c'est très impressionnant avec
l'ajout d'un coup tout d'un coup on vous
dit la reine arrive à ma saucisse quizz
et à ce moment là il ya des pages qui
rentre il ya un trône qui arrive il ya
des types avec des étendards enfin il ya
tout un travail là il ya une dame qui
est à côté et vous n'allez vous ne
parlez pas la reine vous n'allez pas
voir la reine c'est la dame qui est à
côté qui lui dit on va aller voir cette
personne là la reine vient alors ils
bénéficier leur donnant voilà elle vous
dit vous ne parlez pas c'est à c'est à
elle de vous parler à l'arrêt de vous
dit à la dia la personne à qui j'étais à
côté vous trouvez pas qu'il fait beau
aujourd'hui
ah oui aimez-vous l'angleterre et hop
après vous n'appelle attend la réponse
elle vous regarde mais quand elle vous
regarde en fait elle se fout de la
réponse parce que son métier aux
questions au débat passionnant non plus
en ce sens qu'elle vous poser c'est à
dire que son métier ses 300 jours par an
rencontrer des gens à l'inaugurer des
pissotières ouvrir
c'est s'intéresser à des gens qui n'ont
rien à dire qu'il ne l'intéressent pas
elle doit elle doit leur poser une
question et s'y intéressent mais ce
fameux bouquin qui paris où elle
écrivait tout ces gens là lundi le
journal intime est ce que on va pouvoir
un jour savoir comme les dossiers
déclaré wan elle a donné des armes accès
alors elle a donné des ordres ce qu'ils
soient que même son fils je crois ne
pourra pas avoir accès avant 50 ans et
50 ans il a 75 ans enfin il a 74 ans
on a très bon goût mais billy crawford
qui émarge à 80000 euros 80000 euros ont
rappelé à ses avants les preuves
supplémentaires c'est ce qui rafle le
plus derrière on à david douillet le
champion de judokas 60000 euros et vaka
50000 léa et lui florent peyre qui sont
à 40 milles amandine petit la miss
france étaient offerts landaise à 30
mille ans sur fernandez c'est l'étudiant
l'acteur d'études ensuite y en a 3
clément lazzari clémence castel ou
stéphane le gars qui sont à 20000 et
enfin le plus petit cachet de l'histoire
de dalles c'est thomas da costa et 15000
on à françois lui qui avait 5000 euros
l'année dernière et qui à 80000 euros
cette année ouais et on atteint là
s'arrête danseur étoile 1 voilà et en
habile al hassani qui a cinquante mille
euros et c'est le plus bas cachet
historique pour un jury de danse avec
les voilà il se dit pour chris marquez
mais à vérifier que cette bêtise que lui
il a un contrat à l'année avec tf1 parce
qu'il est rapide ce qui serait à 250000
euros par an